hey everyone it's Mike and in this
presentation I talk about order flows
prominent point control and divergence
and your primary point of control is one
of the new additions that we've put out
in the order flows 2.0 software before
we had divergence in the original
software but in the the newer version
we've added a few extra tools and one of
them is the prominent point of control
and what I'm going to talk about today
is how to use them together so before we
begin a brief disclaimer of this
presentation for educational and
informational purposes only and is not
considered a solicitation to buy or sell
a futures contract or make any other
type of investment decision futures
trading contains substantial risk and is
not for every investor investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
once financial security or lifestyle
only risk CalPERS should be history
trading only those with sufficient risk
capital should consider trading past
reports is not necessarily indicative of
future results now the tools I use in
this presentation are the order flows
trader software which you know I
developed together with a programmer and
basically you know I said I was using a
different volume footprint charge and I
told them what I wanted to see in my
volume footprint chart and one of our
early tools was the divergence indicator
as well as the ratios and I've done
videos before on ratios and divergence
but in this particular one I'm gonna
talk about ratios so I only talked about
divergence and prominent point of
control
so what's a prominent point of control
well it will be highlighted in the chart
you know if it's a bearish one it'll be
a magenta color if it's a bullish one
let me see if I find one here I had one
here earlier it'll be a Akwa color now
every bar has a point of control okay
but there's times where based on my
analysis I've found that they can lead
to market reversals and that's why we
call it an aqua or provis or magenta for
sell if it's just gray that's your
normal order flow point of control you
know there's there's nothing spectacular
in it as far as being prominent for
helping see a potential market
turning point now every bar has a point
of control okay
and it's the basically it's just all it
is it's just the point in a bar with the
most volume that's it there's no
special calculations or nothing you know
all it does is find the price level in
the bar with the most volume if there's
what which every bar has won and it just
puts a box around it and primary point
of control is a point control that are
recognized as important important in the
order flow analysis and it often occurs
at market turns and provides support or
resistance in the market okay so now you
know the next thing is is the divergence
order flow divergence occurs when a new
or equal hires made on negative Delta or
when a new or equal low is made on
positive Delta now order flow divergence
is also a potential reversal signal so
you have a prominent point of control
which is a reversal signal you have
order flow divergence which is also a
potential reversal signal now there can
be more than one divergence in a trading
day you know you could keep making new
highs you can keep making new lows
throughout the day so you can have more
than one divergence in a trading day so
you know let's take a look at some
charts here and this is e minis this 8
range chart you know people ask me you
know hey what's the best chart to look
at it really comes down to you as a
trader what you like to how you like to
trade you know your mental mindset and
you know what I like charts I like to
look at probably somebody else doesn't
like to look at you know that's fine you
know that's what makes the market you
know is is people trade on different
time frames with different opinions in
the market so what a divergence is again
you know is you have a new or equal low
with a positive Delta like you see here
74 and you have this green arrow which
indicates a potential buy ok now a red
one well you can't see it there you see
here you can see here the red it's nice
that arrow it's more of a triangle
it's got negative Delta right at the new
high right you had negative Delta at the
high what does that mean well you you're
at a high you got aggressive sellers
coming into the market and here you have
a prominent point of control it's
colored magenta so I know I've got
resistance up here in the point of
control and I've got aggressive sellers
coming in so what do I have markets
rallied up to a level there's resistance
and aggressive sellers are also coming
in
so it's like you hit a level man you
know you hit a level where that you know
there's gonna be resistance in the
market and you add to that aggressive
sellers coming in you know that that's
what you want as a trader I mean those
are the points that you're looking for
you know they're gonna give you good
training opportunities you know if
you're just buying or selling every
divergence by itself you know there's
gonna be times you know on a market
that's falling you know market sells off
a little bit of buying coming in you get
the positive Delta Chi divergence do you
buy it there you know can I reverse of
course it can but can keep going down
can keep making new lows yeah the market
bounces off the lows all the time and
then continues making new lows you know
really what you want to be looking for
is some sort of supportive buying as
well in the market so what I'm looking
for is you know the red triangle and a
magenta color or a green triangle and a
and a and uh aqua color so you know here
you got you got a nice straight here
this is again it's a rainy mini chart
you know 2720 all the way down to 27 14
you got a couple prime opponent controls
here no divergence because it's not at
the high
you got some resistance market just you
know it just sort of goes sideways here
it doesn't really go anywhere then you
get up here you have the divergence you
got a ratio that's also a trade I like
to take then you got here in the next
one you came up and made a new high by a
tick and you got a divergence again and
you got the prominent point of control
again same thing we sell off from the
27:33 area all the way down down down
into the 27 you know what is this 2728
area down here you got some supportive
buying you can see in the prominent
point of controls you don't have
divergence come back up here you bounce
up to a resistance area you just sort of
going sideways at this time then finally
you break down got some support here
market goes sideways and market starts
to break down too breaks out below the
support what do you got you know support
becomes resistance boom you got a
prominent point of control bearish one
right here market sells off where's it's
all off to it sells off down to this
area where you got some supportive
buying you don't have a divergence
unfortunate because it's not a new low
but you do have the positive Delta in
the market
makes us nice rally up there I mean
earlier he's from 27 20 all the way up
to the 30s then what happens you get up
here you got a great show and divergence
which is also another trade I like I
mentioned that earlier I've done many
videos on that and you know you start to
sell off in here
you got the primary point control well
here okay so you hit this swing high
bounce off come down to support here
then rally up to this divergence so
again prominent point control acting as
support you notice you can almost draw a
line out here like this where you had
you came right down to the surface to
the exact tick or not of that prominent
point of control and then you bounce
back up another five points more or less
till you get up here to this primary
point of control no divergence and a
sell-off and then you started going into
the close for the day yeah that's the
end of the trading day then into the the
next day what do you got here this is
right after the reopen you got a
divergence and prominent point control
this one falls apart this is you know
within the first hour of the reopen of
forgot what day that was that was a July
fourth or something like that what is
that no July fifth then you get down
here so you get stopped out on this
trade okay but then boom you get another
trade supported buying in the primary
point of control and divergence and then
why can't rallies you know it just keeps
going up I'll hop up you know from 27 35
all the way up into the 40s no no
bearish point controls bearish point
control so you get up to here 27:46 no
divergence you hit an area in here of
some support market does bounce up a
little bit and falls down comes down to
this area of support prominent point of
control again you know you can see how
these prominent opponent controls are
holding you know how they react in the
market you know if you know here that
hey you know what I have some support
maybe I throw a bit in in here for the
pullback you know it's gonna give you a
low rest rate because where's your stop
going to be your stops gonna be just
below the low of this bar okay so I mean
that that's what you know when people
talk about having low risk trades you
know with tight stops these are those
types of trades that you can take you
know you're risking you know maybe a
point to get you know how many points
you know from 35 all the way up to 40
you know that's risk one point to get
five points you got a prominent point of
control bearish one up here no
divergence market does market does
sell-off then you get down into this
divergence no problem important control
plus the divergence and a ratio and the
market rallies up and I'm just trying to
find the next one here you got a problem
point of control here no divergence
market just sort of go sideways rally up
here rally opinion here you got
divergence and probably point of control
market doesn't really sell off you do
make a new high by a couple of ticks
because two ticks tries to sell off here
doesn't happen then you rally back up
get a new high prominent point of
control and a divergence and you know
the market put sells off a little bit
you know it's not the greatest trade but
you know from sixty three and a half
down to 60 and a half sixty four it
rallies back up in here and that was it
so you know that's on the e-mini eight
range chart but again let's take a look
at a different chart this is crude oil
alright so just again I'll just go back
to the beginning here see what there is
so here's just a divergence by itself
right after the reopen another
divergence no prominent point of control
you got a problem a point of control
first one here at just after midnight
this is July fifth and market does rally
rallies up through an area we got
prominent important control resistance
and you come off a little bit probably
point of control those don't really work
out and you get one here I just go
sideways afterwards sideways so you know
you've got some resistance up in here
right here at around the 14/15 area and
you're sort of hanging around you go in
sideways sideways before you put in this
nice little rally again this one this
one fails there's no other way to say it
here you got a prominent point of
control no divergence mark comes off a
little bit get down in here 753 I know
at this time there's mark
moving pretty fast I could see it's a
range chart you know get 753 everybody
got three bars forming okay here's a
prominent point of control for
resistance mica sells off we rally back
up or do you rally back up to again you
rally back up to the literally to that
to that point of control you know people
always wonder you know I did some market
just rally right back up that level or
rallies back up that level because you
have resistance there and again you know
this is sort of the beauty of
understanding order flow that hey you
know what I got some resistance here I
can just throw in an offer I'll say take
a shot but you know if you know there's
resistance here in the point of control
then you know is it was it worth to you
to throw in an offer somewhere right
around that point of control and maybe
you know risk two or three ticks and get
filled and hopefully you know you're
risking two or three to get ten or
fifteen back yeah you know you do that
all day long you know I mean these
pointed controls you know there's
nothing special in these in the order
flows but you can see how oftentimes
these prominent point controls the
market rallies or sells off back you
know it retraces right back to those
levels you know like this one say you
want to take a shot here you get short
here throw an offer here okay you can
stop tout you know that's not the end of
the world you're gonna get stopped out
we would you rather take you know two or
three tick loss to get back you know 10
15 20 ticks yeah of course you know
you're gonna have a few loss and others
you had some data come out here that's
why there's markets in fast market mode
the ninja trader can't keep up with the
data that's coming out it's one of the
drawbacks they're dealing with ninja
trader then here you get down here you
got a problem opponent control this 1030
I don't know if you were taking that
because it's only 13 seconds 10 o'clock
in 13 seconds afterwards primary point
of control and the divergence Mike does
rally or is it rally up to an area where
you get prominent point of control and
just sort of hangs around that area but
then later down here
10:08 probably the point of control and
divergence you start a new rally 72 73
bucks you know up to an area that's the
primary point of control up here at 73
15 primary point of control just for
those sideways another primary point
control mark came off power point of
control for support
market rallied it's not a divergence in
the sense of a new low then again you
got another prominent point controlling
here for resistance and the market
settles off get down here probably point
of control for support market rallies
another prominent point of control for
support market rallies a bearish point
of control here again you know market
came back up there and you know is it
worth it to sell it at 27 and cover it
down here at 17 you know for a quick 10
ticks and you're gonna risk you know one
two three ticks you know those those are
I like to say no-brainer trades but
again you know those are those type of
traits you know are you gonna risk you
know buying it here at 7310 for a
pullback trades down 208 again if you're
risking to you'd be stopped out if
you're risking three you wouldn't and it
rallies from Oh 8 all the way up to I'm
sorry from 10 all the way up to 20 to 23
probably opponent controlling divergence
this one fails another one here fails
but then again you know you take the two
losses there okay you know you move on
it's not like oh you know I got a loss
here you got a loss here mike says you
gotta trade these and but I had two
losses in a row okay well you know what
you keep trading you don't just give up
you don't say oh you know I got to start
handicapping every trade that comes
along no you wait for the next trade
boom here it is okay here's your
divergence and your primary point of
control and you're getting along
somewhere in here called 7265 what
happens market shoots all the way up you
know up to 73 bucks up here we got this
bearish prominent point of control then
you just sort of go sideways going into
the evening session this is for the
sixth yeah you got some problem opponent
controls here probably point there's a
ratio and divergence not a prominent
point of control problem point of
control for support and look how how
this market comes back you know this is
why you know I don't say I spent all
this time doing this analysis but this
is analysis that I've done and there's a
reason why the markets pull back because
you have supportive buying in here
first time it happened so you know he
could be getting along in here and
risking just a few ticks to three ticks
on the trade if you can get filled here
that's great you know you're buying in
at 73
double-o you know you can take it up to
ten or twelve you know those are those
low restrains you're risking two or
three Chick Hicks to get back you know
10 12 15 20 ticks here's a nice problem
this time it didn't pull back but you
know you got your prominent point of
control the bearish sign their market
sells off okay this one again you get
some data in Europe come out so I sort
of fast market I yeah I'm not gonna say
well you could trade the pullback up
there
when it's fast market like that you
sometimes you get the apartment
important controls and I don't say it's
it's pointless but it's you know take it
with a grain of salt when markets in
fast market mode probably point of
control and the divergence market does
rally a little bit before coming back
down in here and making the new lower
you have the divergence in a ratio then
you get a nice little rally going on
here
this one you don't have a divergence you
do have the prominent point of control
though market does rally up off that you
so you have to support of point of
control again you know eight o'clock
prominent point of control right here no
divergence rallies up to an area where
you got some resistance selling just
sort of go sideways and get another
prominent point of control market
rallies up to a area of prominent point
of control market sells off a little bit
you know here another primary point of
control
market rallies up to an area where you
got prominent point of control for
resistance down to an area were
supportive again and the market goes
back up and we just sort of go sideways
in here again you know you have your
primary point of control here
73 31 you throw in an offer here 31 you
know take it up to 33 and your stop
maybe at 34 I'd go above the high at
least and you know you're risking three
ticks they're getting short at 30 you
know the trades down to 20 it gets down
to 19 so you know you at least could
have got 10 ticks out of there hopefully
another problem to point control this
one again explain
back when you stopped you out but then
again you know if you're playing the
pullback on this next one again at 34 or
is the market trade up to it's trades up
to 36 got three ticks top you know 34
maybe recovering it down here at 24
that's 10 ticks yet another prominent
point of control no divergence on this
one rally up to an area where you got
another problem opponent control you got
bullish part opponent control rallies up
to a bearish prominent party control
market sells off bullish one fails and
bearish one that fails then again you
know you got these primary opponent
controls here you know you maybe take a
shot or an offer up in here get filled
you know eighty six doesn't quite get
down seven you know just give you the 10
ticks just sort of hangs around there
before selling off and then you get
another bullish primary point of control
was the market do it sells out you know
rallies comes right back down to that
level 73 64 then you know from 64 could
at least get 10 ticks 74 you know all
the way up into the 80s you know then
you get stopped you know if you're
trying the same thing here you get
stopped out okay fine you know that's
what it that's what happens in training
you know bullish ground control point of
control that fails and that was it you
know closing out for the day so again
you know probably opponent controls and
divergences you know look for them you
know I know some people that trade each
of them separately but I I know some
people that have been coming back to me
given me some amazing feedback when you
use them together and you know it's just
tools out there that that's available on
the order flows trader software so again
you know if if you're interested in the
order flow software go to order flows
calm to learn more about the training
software that I use in this presentation
so thanks everyone and have a great day
bye-bye